In one cross test, SCP-682, the Hard to Destroy
Reptile, was made to face off against SCP-1361,
a giant, aggressive mass of animal slurry
that envelops and digests everything it touches,
before briefly taking on their traits.
Just over 1000 kilograms of SCP-1361 was poured
onto SCP-682, and it successfully enveloped
the creature.
The problem was that it then began taking
on traits and a temperament incredibly similar
to SCP-682 - After developing legs, jaws and
other physical features similar to the reptile,
it broke out of containment and killed seventeen
members of staff.
After several failed attempts to stop the
creature with small arms fire, it was finally
destroyed by the aerial deployment of napalm.
682’s skeletal carcass was retrieved from
within and placed back in its chamber.
It had regenerated back to perfect health
within a mere six hours.